Even if you make a lot of money from your job,...
...what if you are not satisfied with your current position?
There can be various reasons why you are dissatisfied; mean bosses,...
...stressful work conditions, and so on.
You might consider changing your job many times throughout your working life,...
...but as you all know, changing jobs is not easy.
Here is an interesting thought: Money is the reason a person moves from one company to another,...
...but job satisfaction makes him stay.
Some consultants argue that your current job is a stepping stone to a better career,...
...which will lead you to earn more money and feel more satisfied.
You should not leave just because you don't make as much money as you want now,...
...or because you just hate your boss.
Keep in mind that our future is always affected by our present decisions.